I was raised by my maternal grandmother
when she was 6 years old her mother died
and her father snatched her out of
school and she was devastated she talked
about that a lot so she got married
later of course and had six children and
she had an absentee husband in my
grandfather and so they never really got
the education that she had wanted for
her children so what happened was I came
along when I am my grandmother's baby
daughter made his daughter and when I
got to school went to school for the
first time I really was already driven
by her I was very afraid in school
because there were so many books and I
wondered how would I ever have the time
to read all of them however what I
discovered was I was very good at school
and very good at reading and writing and
I looking back I know now that my
grandmother had passed the fire on to me
for education and knowledge so when she
would have her friends come to visit
they were of course older people people
and they would ask her how was I doing
in school and she would just beam and
say that I was doing great and that that
I could read very well and I probably
was I don't know eight and ten something
like that and they would say have her
read for me and they would go usually
they would want me to read the Bible
usually that that was what they wanted
me to do and when I would read it they
would cry most of them will cry and so
what I learned in that was that
education knowledge reading was very
powerful so
they would say lord have mercy this baby
can read my grandmother of course was
very proud when I went to junior high
school I was writing poetry for
boyfriends and girlfriends to each other
and make them look money on side so that
was pretty cool my grandmother died when
I was 15 so I was very sad and actually
still says sometimes a day because she
was such a powerful influence on my life
oh let me back up when I was in the
house with my grandmother being raised
in the house my grandmother my
grandmother aid would not buy a
television set she said that it was an
idiot box and I asked what should i do
then for entertainment she said write
your own stores so I would whip out but
I would snuggle up in a corner and start
to write my own stories so that was
basically how it got started I then got
married myself and raised the Sun and I
moved to Los Angeles in 2006 to become a
working writer and oddly enough I had
tried to do it from my home state of
Florida but it really is impossible to
to do something this of this magnitude
from that far away and nobody knows who
you are so I work every day at my craft
however I not made the money yet but
it's a it's a big dream that I have
stepped out here on faith to accomplish
I have several pieces copy written and
that includes some features and some
comedy shorts I'm working on a new
screenplay now and typically I write a
lot of historical pieces because there
aren't enough pieces written written
about blacks being patriotic or marry
nor loving or raising children
or being good citizens it's just not
enough good material so I do a lot of
research which I thoroughly enjoy and I
absolutely think my grandmother for give
me the fire that I still carry and the
desire to become successful and what I
know to be the truth is that I am the
voice for her my great-grandmother and
my great-great-grandmother because they
really were proponents of education and
they came along at a time in this
country where they were denied for one
reason or another so I always carried
them with me and at some point in time I
will be able to tell the world that I am
sarah prefers granddaughter Mahela
Jenkins Leon great-granddaughter and
Sarah Barnes is great great
granddaughter and that I accomplished
what they wanted me to accomplish in
life in this world and certainly
education was always at the top of a
list for them thank you